welcome back should leftist groups be
ashamed when thugs get money but victims
get blamed true it appears gofundme
backers can only help attackers
go fund me the website where i pretend
to raise money for orphans
speak called out for hosting a
fundraising page for a gunman after
deleting one for a new york bodega clerk
who fought off and killed an attacker
andrew sunberg who had fired shots into
an apartment of a young mother and her
two kids was killed by cops after a
six-hour standoff last week a few days
later the mother confronted blm
protesters who'd gathered outside her
home to do to decry the cops
that man was armed george blood was not
armed brianna taylor was not armed this
man intentionally tried to kill us for
three years i lived here and none of you
guys knocked that at me store to see if
he was okay there was casings in the
hallway
this shot went through my door to the
pillar to the kitchen i was cooking food
for my kids y'all should have came and
helped her when he was alive my kids
have to see you guys celebrate a man's
life to try to kill him there you go
not bad
arabella fossiarbro a woman of color was
shocked to learn that not wanting to be
murdered along with her children makes
her a white supremacist
now while that was happening the
gofundme page for the guy who shot at
her
what raised over 20 grand
now compare that to the page for the
bodega worker jose alba who killed an
ex-con in self-defense and then got
charged with murder apparently he's the
only murder suspect activists aren't
defending
his fundraiser was yanked shortly after
was posted because the company says they
prohibit fundraising for the legal
defense of a violent crime in other
words there's different rules for a guy
defending himself and a guy who nearly
killed a mom and two young children
but sanity prevailed on tuesday
manhattan d.a alvin bragg dropped the
murder charges against alba after an
investigation found they couldn't prove
he wasn't justified in his use of deadly
physical force but don't pat brag on the
back he may charge you for attempted
murder
tyrus uh what do you make of the the the
mother shouting at the blm protesters
well on unfortunately
this was actually caught on film
because there's a lot of this from my
from the community because
they're not interested in any
actual
black person's plight or persons at all
they have just as much interest as a
klansman would the difference was the
only reason why they were there was
because the words cop was involved and
that's the best way to get money once
again white cops killed an innocent
brother trying to do his thing and
that's their narrative and most people
won't check facts they won't look
they'll cut checks and it's
disparaging and it's crushing to see the
exploitation of
my own people by our own people which
seems to be more dangerous than any
other group they don't care if we kill
each other they won't do they won't buy
a school computer for chicago they won't
do a damn thing unless somehow it works
its way to where they can get a mansion
or they can get a plane it's all about
making money off the blood
of our own people and it's disgusting
her fight
they didn't care yeah in the this part
in the video we saw
her
there's a reason why she's screaming
she was being surrounded
and you look at the video and the
approach don't touch me don't get in my
face you're in front of her house her
children were in that car yeah this is a
sister and you did not care because the
woke don't listen to reason and facts
their narrative was another white cop
did something and they didn't care what
the facts were and they are anticipating
inspecting that most of not us not
because we know what's up they expect
most white americans to hear that and
get the guilty thing going and not say
anything and cut checks and apologize
for white privilege when they're
exploiting all that so hopefully that
might not have been an intention i think
all she wanted to do is get her children
inside who had been through hell those
kids will never be the same again
inadvertently this might be the thing
that makes america wake up stop writing
checks to black life matters stop
donating to you want to do something buy
it buy a laptop for a school
become a big brother
become a foster parent if you really
care you want to do something for your
community and people in your community
but stop giving money to this because
you are supporting hate and division
because that's all that they're about
i've tried you know i've tried to be a
big brother but they won't let me
it's a height restriction it's not your
fault
adam uh what do you make of this
i think i found my next nanny
i like the cut of this woman's gym i
would hire her to do anything yes she is
what i call a cracker jack yeah and she
by the way she
emotes better than any actress i've seen
in the last 40 years on the silver
screen
she's got it i hope somebody sees her
and throws uh the best job that was fun
i was thinking the same thing because i
i think i saw the clip like on a phone
and i didn't really get it all then i'm
looking at her and i'm like she's got
something she's got it yeah she's got it
yeah yeah i i don't know i thought this
black lives matters thing was sort of
done when they bought the six million
dollar house and paid the brother 850
grand it's always a grift it never helps
it's insane
that they can keep it you know al
sharpton or whomever this grift they can
you know they can go for 50 years on
this grift nothing changes i mean the
mayors of a lot of big cities are go
right along with the ride on the grift
more kids killed every year
still folks even merrick garland and
it's in it's insane that as a country
we're able to go along on this grift and
i think it's the large group of scared
people in the middle who just don't want
any problems you know when the whole
black box twitter twitter thing came on
i was told on my uh my podcast like my
producer said oh no you you got to do it
and i said i'm not doing it they said no
you have to or we'll get into trouble
and i said
do you agree with it he said it doesn't
matter
that's where we're at scared people
getting in line going along and not
pushing back
kat uh you're an expert in fundraising
explain to me how
gofundme can do this they can
i don't know i just came up with a
question that doesn't make any sense
great job
no i well i don't think i guess they can
do sort of whatever they want
but i mean
watching that video i don't know how you
could not be affected by it
because of course i mean look if we get
body cam footage maybe the cops you know
they could have done something more
other than shoot the guy who who knows
it doesn't change the fact that this guy
was shooting into an apartment with a
woman and her kids in it earlier than
that and it's deeply wrong and clearly
and obviously wrong to post up outside
where she and her kids are and be
celebrating the guy who was shooting at
them regardless of anything else that
happened and i just think that this is
what happens when you decide the
narrative first before anyone knows
anything
um i think that if you really cared
about these issues you'd want to make
sure that you're really throwing your
support around behind ones that are
worthy of support and not
celebrating this could have been
murderer in front of a woman and her
kids last word morgan what say you can
be about meghan markle if you like
i'm sure meghan markle would like this
segment to be about her oh yeah um no
what's really interesting to me is uh we
have the the bodega worker how did joe
biden call it the bogota worker um who
uh who you know they dropped the charges
today but he had to post 250 000 in bail
for defending himself and so when you
look at major cities around america you
have small business owners who are
seeing their businesses since 2020
burned to the ground or they're having
criminals come in and stealing things i
mean there's not a day that you don't
see on twitter
i think i just saw yesterday in l.a
where they were stealing watches and
purses and so i feel for small business
owners especially in the retail space
around america you know this guy was
going to get killed self-defense and
then because it's not politically
correct by the way he's charged with
murder thank god it got dropped
everything was dropped and that wasn't
because alvin bragg is because of the
public outcry the new york post putting
stuff on the cover fox covering i mean
it was like that's what people have to
do now they can't rely on our
politicians you got to do it yourself
get out there and yell as loud as they
are except for me i'm lazy
i won't go anywhere hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else